und wir müssen putin genau zuhören denn
er kündigt an was er was er tun will und
der tus dann tatsächlich auch die rede
die ihr heute morgen an seine nation
gehalten hat als er angekündigt hat wir
greifen jetzt die ukraine an nämlich
wegen des genozids der dort stattfindet
gegen büros ische bürger gegen russische
abstammende und auch wegen der bedrohung
die aus der ukraine insgesamt ansteht
wir schauen uns an was er heute morgen
30 deutscher zeit gesagt hat
das nordatlantische
sich nun die ukraine aneignen das werden
wir nicht akzeptieren
es gibt natürlich dabei nicht nur um die
nato ist lediglich ein instrument der
außenpolitik
das problem liegt darin dass das
angrenzende gebiet das historisch zu uns
gehört
komplett von außen kontrolliert wird es
wird ständig durch nato-staaten mit
waffen folge punkt und zwar mit dem
modernsten state of the art waffen
hierbei wird eine politik betrieben die
russland zurückhalten soll für unser
land geht es jedoch dabei um leben und
tod es geht um unsere zukunft um unsere
historische zukunft als volk und das ist
leider die wahrheit das ist wie es ist
es geht um die zukunft unseres landes um
unsere souveränität es ist genau die
rote linie die ich mehrfach erwähnt habe
es war für uns nicht mehr möglich das
alles zu erdulden wir mussten diesen
albtraum beenden müssen den genozid
gegen die bevölkerung in der ukraine
aufhalten denn diese menschen können
leider nur auf uns hoffen auf unsere
unterstützung
und genau das war der anreiz für unsere
entscheidung die selbsternannten
volksrepublik lorenz und donetsk
anzuerkennen das war das bestreben
dieser menschen die sich an uns gewandt
haben
deswegen ist klar geworden dass es
unabdingbar ist dass es zu einer solchen
konfrontation kommt wir wussten die
ukraine wartet nur auf einen günstigen
moment ab es ist immerhin ein atomstaat
anscheinend darum das wurde in jüngster
zeit immer häufiger erwähnt so wurden
sich an uns gewandt wir wurden um hilfe
gebeten
deswegen werden wir jetzt handeln
und wir halten uns dabei stets an
die vorgaben in diesem zusammenhang habe
ich gemäß artikel 51 absatz 7 der un
skater mit genehmigung des
föderationsrates und in übereinstimmung
mit den vor der föderation versammlung
ratifizierten freundschaft und beistands
verträgen mit der donezker volksrepublik
und der yuan sga volksrepublik
beschlossen eine besondere militär
operation durchzuführen
deswegen werden wir stets die
demilitarisierung der ukraine
anstreben wir haben nicht vor die ganze
ukraine zu besetzen aber sie zudem mit
dem militarisieren das ziel der
russische spezialoperation ist es die
menschen zu schützen die acht jahre lang
vom kabarett sie misshandelt und
ermordet wurden zu diesem zweck werden
wir versuchen die ukraine cent
militarisieren und zu entnazifiziert und
diejenigen vor gericht zu bringen die
zahlreiche blutige verbrechen gegen die
zivilbevölkerung
verübt haben
ich wiederhole noch mal was wir tun ist
selbst verteidigen
wenn wir nicht handeln wird es noch
schwerere schlimmere weitreichendere
konsequenzen haben als die die wir heute
sehen deswegen möchten wir diese dieses
tragische kapitel der geschichte so
schnell wie möglich schließen wir werden
aber nicht gestatten dass sich ständig
eingemischt wird in unsere beziehungen
und unser handeln
es kann nicht sein dass der nötige
kontext uns verwehrt bleibt
wir wollen gestärkt herausgehen und zwar
von innen aus dieser krise wir glauben
an eine solche zukunft russlands meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren ihre
väter großväter und urgroßväter haben
nicht gegen die nazis gekämpft unser
gemeinsames vaterland zu verteidigen
damit die heutigen neonazis die macht in
der ukraine übernehmen können ich
fordere euch auf die kriminellen befehle
nicht auszuführen
sie dürfen den aufrufen der ukrainischen
armee nicht folgen dem blutigen aufrufen
nicht gerecht werden
alle mitglieder der ukrainischen armee
die unseren forderungen nachkommen
werden die möglichkeit bekommt ihren
familien zurückzukehren alle soldaten
der ukrainischen armee
sie müssen dieser forderung hierdurch
nachkommen wir respektieren die
souveränität aller neu entstanden länder
im postsowjetischen raum und werden dies
auch weiterhin tun
sie möchten niemanden bedrohen aber wir
möchten auch nicht dass unser volk
bedroht wird alle müssen wissen dass
wir sofort reagieren und es werden
solche folgen entstehen die sie in ihrer
geschichte noch nie erlebt haben wir
sind bereit zu
entwicklung vor der wir uns wiederfinden
werden die entscheidung ist gefallen und
ich hoffe meine worte werden gehört
diese worte werden leider gehört und sie
sind sehr bitter
krass müsste man sagen und sie sind
schon fast absurd er spricht von
selbstverteidigung und von bedrohung die
ukraine könnte angreifen er
verschwurbelt irgendwas mit atomwaffen
in der ukraine
das kann man ja an sich gar nicht mehr
ernst nehmen aber es ist ernst das ist
bitter ernst müsste was macht eigentlich
fassungslos vor solchen redens thema
davor also wovon redet er ist der im
inneren auch so isoliert dass er nur
haben sie schnell um sich schlägt nur
noch eine eigene eine eigene wahrnehmung
eine eigene wirklichkeit hat natürlich
ist so eine rede für den
innenpolitischen gebrauch
zunächst gesprochen sich er rechtfertigt
dies nicht rechtfertigen vor seinen
eigenen leuten und den kann er erzählen
dass sie die die idee die russen in
diesen provinzen verfolgt worden sein
auch wenn sie stimmt die können es ja
nicht nachprüfen dort gibt es keine
freie presse gibt es keinen journalisten
die das nachher schüler also er hat
sozusagen das meinungsmonopol und darauf
reitet er und und er muss natürlich auch
weil das natürlich genau weiß ist können
sie das jetzt wirtschaftlich für ihn
noch schwieriger es kommen in behrungen
ob das volk zu da muss das sagen leute
dass deswegen müsst ihr das machen dann
kann er jetzt auch alles machen also
wenn wir schon davon von atomwaffen
bedrohung zumindest angedeutet das wird
wahrscheinlich noch mal deutlicher
kommen aus der ukraine spricht dann hat
er ja quasi alles in der hand an
argumenten um zu sagen so jetzt haben
wir da alles kurz und klein ja dann ist
die ukraine ja wirklich tot also
darum zumindest bereit könnte man das
außerdem schließen wobei ich immer noch
sage wenn die ukraine das abkommen den
90er jahren nicht abgeschlossen hätte
dass sie den nuklear zurückgibt gegen
die garantien die jetzt nicht eingelöst
werden wenn die ukraine sogar waffen
hätte würde er denn hier angreifen
allerdings hätte das ist ein gutes
argument also das ist schon auch
gesichert dass da alle ehemaligen
atomwaffen die dort stationiert waren
alle aus herausgefahren wurden und nach
russland gelang ja das war ja damals
verändernder phase wäre der der der
harmonie in den 90er jahren wo man wo
man dachte jetzt gehen wir in eine in
eine friedliche zukunft ein friedliches
europa da gab es keinen misstrauen
inzwischen kehrt von moskau den
patienten die das ja nie unterschrieben
also von daher denn er ist ich habe auch
noch nie irgendwo gehört dass irgendeine
von diesen möglichen waffen
zurückbehalten worden wäre und die die
die techniker die die das gebaut haben
die sind alle in
russland gewesen also ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass wir keine irgendeiner
versteckt schublade oder unter dem
schreibtisch noch solche ratschlägen hat
da gibt es überhaupt keinen einzigen
hinweis aber es gibt doch auch in
russland sicherlich menschen die ein
bisschen mehr nachdenken als nur das
nachzuplappern was sie aus den
russischen medien erfahren die dann
irgendwann mal sagen moment mal
selbstverteidigung und bedrohung habe
ich bisher noch gar nicht auf dem schirm
notfalls auch militärisch oder ist das
militär so hinter putin aufgestellt dass
der irgendwann
durchregieren durchregieren kann wäre ja
weil es ist ja so darauf hat heute früh
der einstellung haben wir auch schon der
cdu vorsitzende märz hingewiesen dass
wir hinter ja ja ja gleich darauf machen
was an dieser stelle dann schauen wir zu
friedrich merz
das ist für mich ein schlüssel weil er
hat gesagt in dem moment wo es in der in
weißrussland die demokratiebewegungen
gegeben hat er hat sich der ton und der
umgang von russland mit der ukraine
verschärft und das kann ein schlüssel
sein
weil er einfach angst hat vor
demokratischen bewegungen die auch
überschreiben können dass das im grunde
das was in der ukraine auf dem majdan
geklappt hat in belarus auch noch klappt
und das alles in den westen bringen
[Musik]